Apple needs Samsung let me put that
another way Apple needs someone to
manufacture in OLED screens on its brand
new flagship smartphone in the iPhone 10
and Samsung its biggest smartphone
competitor is the only company that can
do it if you're wondering how Samsung
stock price could look like this in a
year when the company had to replace
then fully recall an exploding phone in
a year when its de-facto chief executive
was sentenced to five years in jail for
bribery and embezzlement this is how
most people know Samsung as the company
that sells them smart phones and TVs
even refrigerators but the strongest
part of its business is actually the
components it builds for other companies
namely memory chips and displays like
the OLED display that's going into the
iPhone 10 in these two key divisions
Samsung has the ability to supply
products quickly to meet a gargantuan
worldwide demand the name of the game is
market share they of course supply their
own devices with these components but
they want everyone else to turn to them
too and they're investing heavily almost
19 billion dollars on new plants in the
next four years to grab a bigger slice
of that pie
in July of this year Samsung overtook
Intel as the world's number one chip
maker and their dominance in OLED is
even more extreme as of the beginning of
2017 Samsung had over 90% of the OLED
market share basically a monopoly which
means when demand for OLED grows like it
has with the iPhone Samsung grows to
Apple you might guess hates the
situation because Samsung is the only
OLED maker in the world who can handle
the demand for new iPhones Samsung gets
to set the price for reference egi
securities estimates that Samsung will
charge Apple around 120 to 130 dollars
for each oled screen compared to old LCD
screens which only cost Apple about 45
to 55 dollars
this may be a contributor to the hefty
$1,000 price tag on the iPhone 10 this
sort of thing has to especially are Tim
Cook Apple's CEO cooks expertise is in
supply chain the process of how products
get made and distributed to customers
and when he joined Apple in 1998 he was
instrumental in overhauling the supply
chain and making it the most efficient
in the world one of the ways Apple does
this is by outsourcing pretty much all
of its production to suppliers mostly in
Asia who compete for their business but
in the case of OLED screens Apple has no
other choice but to go with Samsung
Apple won at 80 million OLED screens
just for the second half of 2017 no one
else can do that
Samsung barely has the capacity which is
one of the reasons why the iPhone 10
comes out six weeks later than the
iPhone 8 in order to bring its OLED
costs down Apple meets for there to be a
serious competitor in the space which is
why it's investing 2.7 billion dollars
in LG Display basically a massive cash
advance for them to build up their
capacity Google has the same idea it's
investing 880 million dollars into LG to
break the samsung monopoly for the near
future though it doesn't quite matter
Samsung is likely to be the major
beneficiary of Apple's OLED needs at
least through 2019 not to mention that
they'll also be making a huge number of
a series chips for Apple - and it's one
of the strangest relationships in
business Apple and Samsung have been
feuding for years ever since 2010 when
Samsung essentially copied the iPhone
with their Galaxy S smartphone the two
companies have been locked in a legal
war for almost seven years that has cost
Samsung 150 million dollars and maybe
more in the end it seems silly because
Apple is still shelling out millions
upon millions to its archrival for parts
bolstering Samsung's huge profits and
its growth the iPhone X is sort of the
perfect symbol for the whole messy
relationship and it captures how the
tech business works at the very highest
level it's dysfunctional marriages like
this Apple needs Samsung yeah but
Samsung is certainly profiting from the
business in other words these two mega
companies really need each other
hey everybody thank you so much for
watching this episode was brought to you
by Squarespace if you want to make a
website and you want it to be a really
easy process Squarespace has some
beautiful award-winning designer
templates to choose from that makes the
process so simple it's got 24-hour
customer service no upgrades nothing to
install no patches ever and picking your
domain name is really easy you can start
your free trial at squarespace.com and
if you use the offer code nerdwriter you
can get 10% off your first purchase
thanks guys I'll see you next time